[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]
JOHN HSU: Hi,
everyone, and welcome.
Thank you for joining us today
whether you're here in person
or joining us in--
tuning in on the live stream.
Yesterday during the keynote,
we announced Interactive Canvas,
a new set of tools
that allow developers
to create visual content
for the Google Assistant.
Today, we want to
talk to you about how
you can use this technology
to build interactive games
for the Google Assistant.
First, a quick
introduction, though.
I'm John Hsu.
I'm the product manager
for Interactive Canvas
and for games on
Google Assistant.
And I'm joined by
Leon Nicholls, who's
on our developer relations team.
10 years-- the
past 10 years, I've
had the pleasure of building
games for new platforms.
From web games to social games
to mobile games to voice games.
What I'm excited about whenever
a new technology comes out
is the fact that a
transformative type
of experience starts to
emerge for the player.
And in addition to that,
a transformative type
of experience allows
new developers
to enter the marketplace and
create these experiences.
What we believe the Google
Assistant and Interactive
Canvas unlocks
together is a new way
and a new potential for players
to engage with our games.
I'm excited for everyone here
to start building visual games
on Google Assistant.
First, let's talk a little bit
about games on the Assistant
today.
The past two years,
we've seen good traction
on voice games
built for Assistant.
Developers have crafted
great interact experiences,
like Akinator and
Trivia Crack, that
really take advantage of
what Google Assistant is
meant to do.
Understand what
the user is saying.
These games have been
successful at creating
immersive experiences with
only audio as the output.
Last year, when we announced
smart displays, we were able--
we're starting to see
increased engagement
from players that on these--
excuse me, on these
display devices.
Over the course of
2019, the percentage
of smart homes that now
include a smart display device
has quadrupled from less
than 3% to over 13%.
Canvas is the tool
that will unlock
these visual capabilities in
conjunction with Google's NLU--
natural language understanding--
and speech recognition.
Canvas essentially gives you
full access to the display.
You can create fluid animations
and custom game experiences
with technology that you're
already familiar with.
HTML, CSS, JavaScript,
and even WebAssembly.
Pairing these
visual capabilities
with our speech
recognition allows
you to create
transformative experiences.
This technology is
available on Android devices
and our smart displays, with
more surfaces coming soon.
Let's take a quick example--
quick look.
Let's take a quick
look at the examples
and see what's possible.
HQ University, as you saw
in the keynote yesterday,
leverages HTML animations
to create a high quality
experience for the user.
In addition to just
having animations,
we have the
capability to leverage
those animations to create
moments of user payoff
when they get the
answer correct.
Lucky Trivia, also known
as, Are You Feeling Lucky?,
uses a similar technique
to provide payoff.
But also uses the visual
surface to simplify
multiplayer experiences.
When you only have audio output,
it's often very difficult
to keep track in a trivia
game of whose turn it is,
who made what answer.
Enough so that Lucky
Trivia team actually--
in the voice only experience--
changed the
interaction models so
that you actually
sequentially ask questions
to different players.
With a visual surface
though, Lucky Trivia
can take advantage
of the visual display
to effortlessly show
who's making the answer,
and more importantly,
who got the answer right.
Finally, in our
sandbox, in sandbox.h,
we are displaying a
new interactive game
called Jungle
Dream, where we are
leveraging visual puzzles that
can't be done on audio devices.
By allowing the visual surface
to be integrated with your core
mechanic, we are
allowing developers
to create awesome new
experiences that really
utilize this visual surface.
But that's just the beginning.
By the end of this
session, you'll
be equipped to create
even better experiences
than what we've just shown.
Here's how we get started.
LEON NICHOLLS: So let's look
at the technical details.
So Interactive Canvas
uses regular HTML.
That means CSS, JavaScript,
SVG, even WebAssembly.
WebGL has been optimized
for 2D and 3D graphics,
but you can also just use the
standard HTML canvas feature
to do some basic graphics.
You can use the standard
HTML media element
to play audio or video
within the local web app.
We also support the
standard touch events
for both smart displays
and for mobile devices.
Now Interactive Canvas gives
you pixel level control
over the rendering of your UI.
So that means custom
layouts, use your own fonts,
add transitions, add
animations, create a custom GUI.
Create your own custom buttons,
tables, lists, whatever.
All of this is now possible.
So what is an
interactive Action?
Well, it's a
conversational Action.
And just like you create
a conversational Action
in the Actions console.
You do the same with
an interactive Action.
Also, you use our existing tools
like Dialogflow or the Action
SDK.
Now we definitely
recommend using Dialogflow,
it has a very nice grid for
you to easily create intent.
And it has multi-natural
language understanding.
You also write code, which
is the fulfillment that
provides dynamic
responses for your intent.
And now you provide a
new kind of response,
an immersive response.
If you've done a
conversational Action before,
you already know about simple
responses and reach responses.
This is something similar.
So let's go through
all of those in steps.
How do we start creating
an interactive Action?
Now, we're launching Interactive
Canvas for games initially.
So in our Actions console, at
console.actions.google.com,
you select the games
vertical to begin.
Next, you get a list of options
for creating different kinds
of games on our platform.
The first three are
based on templates.
But we're going to pick
the last one, which
is for conversational Action.
Next, in the directory
listing for your project,
you have to ensure that the
category is games and fun.
And there's a new
check box right
at the bottom of the screen
for the Canvas feature.
You have to check that.
And then save it.
Now your project is capable
of using the new feature.
Next, we add the Action.
So we go to the Actions page.
You click on a big blue button.
And now we display a
dialogue with a list
of built-in intents.
Now, built-in intents
is a way for your Action
to tell the Google Assistant
what kind of action it is.
And, also, what kind of
user requests it can handle.
Now, since we are
creating a game,
we're going to pick the
play game built-in intent.
After you've clicked on that,
the Dialogflow GUI is loaded
and you get three intents.
The first one is for the
play game built-in intent.
The second one is the
default fallback intent.
That's what Dialogflow invokes
when none of the other intents
are matched.
And then, thirdly, there is
a default welcome intent.
Now, that gets
invoked when the user
invokes the Action by name.
So the user would say, OK, G.
Talk to conversational Action.
Let's take a look at
the play game intent.
Now, in Dialogflow, it's
actually a play game event.
And you can associate that
event with any other intent.
For example, you could associate
that with the welcome intent
and reuse that intent for
the various different ways
that the user can actually
start your Action.
Dialogflow also has a very
convenient inline editor.
So, right within its
GUI, you can go and write
Node.js code for the Cloud
Functions for Firebase.
Every Dialogflow agent actually
gets a Cloud Function for free.
And we're going to base
all of our examples
on the Cloud Function's syntax.
OK.
Let's start at the beginning.
Let's look at what a
conversational Action
is implemented in Dialogflow.
We start with the user.
The user talks to a
device with a screen.
That information is
passed on to the Actions
on Google Cloud Platform.
Actions on Google realizes,
oh, this particular Action
is implemented in Dialogflow
and forwards it to Dialogflow.
Dialogflow takes the user input,
matches that to an intent,
and then invokes the
associated fulfillment--
the code behind that--
to provide a dynamic response.
And for screens, you
can provide something
like a reach response.
It could be a list, a table.
These are all existing widgets.
That reach response is
forwarded to the device
and it's displayed to the user.
So that's how conversational
Actions work today.
So what is an interactive
Action, also implemented
in Dialogflow.
Well you notice our
diagram is very similar,
but we have this new component.
So, again, let's look
at the life cycle.
The user talks to the device.
That user input is passed
onto Actions on Google.
Actions on Google
invokes Dialogflow.
Dialogflow matches the intent
based on that user phrase.
It then invokes the
associated fulfillment logic.
And it provides a response.
But now it provides a
new kind of response,
an immersive response.
So it's similar to
simple and reach,
but it has some
extra data in there.
As part of the immersive
response, you provide a URL.
That URL is forwarded
to the device.
The device loads the associated
web app from that URL.
When the web app
starts on the device,
it initializes the
Interactive Canvas API.
It also registers
some callbacks.
Now, this is the way to pass
some information to the web
app.
And it's also a
way for the web app
to communicate back
to Actions on Google.
So if you look at
this diagram, it's
very similar to an
existing life cycle
of the conversational Action.
We just now have this new
way of visualizing the Action
on a device with a screen.
But let's look at the code.
Both for the fulfillment,
for the intent,
and also for the WebApp
Logic for your game.
Now the intent fulfillment
needs to provide
an immersive response.
Right?
Actions on Google through
Dialogflow matches the intent.
The intent says,
here's some code.
Invoke that code.
That code generates
an immersive response.
Node.js client library
has been extended
with a new class that's really
called ImmersiveResponse.
Very simple like simple
and reach response.
There's also a new
surface capability.
So, in your fulfillment
code, you can go
and check is the device that
the user is talking to capable
of doing a Canvas experience?
If it is, you can use
immersive response.
If it isn't, use our existing
responses like simple
and reach responses.
As part of the
immersive response,
you need to provide a URL.
It needs to be an
https endpoint.
That gets forwarded
to the device
the device loads the web app.
Let's look at the
fulfillment logic.
So this is our
Cloud Function code.
We're using our
Node.js client library.
And here we have
an intent handler
for the default welcome intent.
Note we're using an instance
of the ImmersiveResponse class.
And there's two pieces of
information you need to pass.
Firstly, the URL.
That's the https
endpoint of your web app.
Secondly, some
state information.
Now here we have a variable
that's initialized to the value
welcome.
But that state object is
actually a JSON object.
So you can parse in any JSON
payload from fulfillment
to your web app.
But for our
examples, we're going
to keep it simple
with simple states.
And that's quite a
common thing for games
to track states from fulfillment
and pass it on to the web app.
So the web app,
it's regular HTML.
You have to write
some JavaScript code.
There's a few things
you need to do.
Firstly, declare
these event callbacks.
Second, you need to
initialize the library
we provide for Canvas.
And, as part of
that, you actually
register those callbacks
with the library.
And then is ready
to accept events.
And then in within
your event handler,
you'll have some custom logic.
That as the events
are coming in,
you'll match that with the
game state within your game.
Now, if you're a web
developer, you're
probably relying on some
popular framework or library.
Those will just work as is.
So if you're using Pixi
or TweenJS or React,
those will work just
fine out of the box.
However, we do recommend you
use a single page application.
And this is important
because you can reuse the web
app across intent invocations.
It also ensures a seamless
UX experience for the user.
Now, we recommend using Firebase
hosting for getting started.
It's actually a super fast
way of updating your web app.
But if you've got an
existing web server,
you can just reuse it for that.
Here's the web app.
This is the HTML code.
So there's a few things you
need to do in your web app.
The first thing is you need
to include our style sheet.
Now on the display--
on the device with a screen--
we add a header at the top.
There's two reasons for that.
One is to brand your action.
And secondly, it allows users to
navigate away from your action.
Now that means you can't
use that area for your game.
And the style sheet
gives you information
about the rest of
the screen that's
available for rendering
your game state.
So that's the first thing.
Secondly, you
include our library.
So this will give you access
to the Interactive Canvas API.
We also have some code
here in our example
in the main doT.js file,
which we'll take a look at.
Now in your web app, we import
and initialize our library.
Once you do that you get access
to a special instance variable
called assistantCanvas.
That is how you
actually call the API.
The very first thing you need
to do when the web app loads
is called the ready method.
And that's how you
register these callbacks
that you've declared in your
JavaScript with the API.
And now it's ready
to accept events.
So yes, a super simple example.
So we've declared one callback.
And we call the
assistantCanvas.ready method.
That's how we invoke the API.
And we're parsing in
reference to those callbacks.
So now, once your web
app have done that--
and typically you should
do this on page load--
it's ready to accept
events based on fulfillment
from your intents.
So, the callbacks for handing
those fulfillment updates.
There is a special
one called onUpdates.
So that-- you needed a clear
function called onUpdate.
As a parameter, the
JSON payload that we
specified in our
fulfillment logic
is parsed in as a parameter.
And then you can unpack that.
And typically that would contain
some game data and some state
information.
And then you synchronize
your local web app state
with the fulfillment state.
Here's an example
that's been fleshed out.
Again, this is the same
callback we looked at before.
You declared this onUpdate--
and onUpdate function.
And the parameter is the
state we got from fulfillment.
Just some very basic logic.
Remember we declared the state
variable as a value of welcome
in our fulfillment.
Here we're just
checking in the web app
whether that is the
state that is passed in
and then do some
associated logic.
And as other states
are coming in,
you can just extend
your switch statement
to add other custom
logic for your game.
Let's go back to fulfillment.
So here's another
intent handler.
So the user said something else.
Another intent got
matched by Dialogflow.
Again, we're using our
Node.js client library
and we are declaring an instance
of the ImmersiveResponse class.
Now, you note there's
no URL, right?
We previously invoked
the welcome intent.
It loaded the web app.
It's on the device.
Waiting for new events.
When you parse in
this information,
it doesn't reload the web app.
It just passes the
state information.
So here we are using the same
state variable we had before,
but now it has a
different value.
Within your web app, you just
extend that switch statement
and now you can check
for the change value
and do something appropriate.
So now we have ways for
parsing information initially
when you load the page and then
subsequently when other intents
are invoked by the user.
OK.
So now we know how
to get data and state
information from
fulfillment to the web app.
But there actually is
other way for the web app
to invoke intent.
So this is very similar to the
user talking to the device.
That the user provides
voice or keyboard input,
then it invokes an intent.
But now we have an API
to do the same thing.
You can do this
programmatically.
And the API is
called sendTextQuery.
Again, use our assistantCanvas
instance to call that API.
So this is very useful
in your custom GUI
for handling buttons or even
doing asynchronous intent
invocations, which wasn't
possible up until now.
OK, here's a super
simple example.
At the top is the HTML.
We're declaring a button.
And we're just saying, there
is a JavaScript function
that gets called when the
user clicks on the button.
And then in our
function, we are simply
calling the same
text query method
of our assistantCanvas API.
And we parse in a phrase.
So, again, it's like
the user said this,
but you're doing this
programmatically.
That gets passed
on to Dialogflow.
Dialogflow does the same as
it does with the user input.
Matches an intent and
invokes the fulfillment.
Another very useful
feature that is provided
as part of the Interactive
Canvas experience
is the ability to sync audio
with your game animation.
And a lot of our games that we
are showcasing is using that.
So what you do is you
render TTS like you normally
do in a conversational Action.
For example, you might
provide a simple response
in your fulfillment.
But now we have a
special callback
that gets invoked that
tracks the completion
of each part of that TTS.
And, at each time that
callback is called,
you can now synchronize some
game animation or game state
with each of those invocations.
How does this work?
Well, we are
relying on the SSML.
So SSML is something we've
supported from the beginning
with Actions.
It's a super powerful
feature for developers
to basically control the
way the TTS get pronounced.
So developers can
change the pronunciation
of individual
words or sentences.
You can add sound effects.
You can even add
background music.
And in particular
on our platform,
we actually allow you to layer
TTS and various sounds, which
is unique to our platform.
There's is a standard
mark tag in SSML.
And we are using that
for this feature.
So that allows you to
place markers in the TTS
that you're providing
for your response.
And events are generated
for each of those
when the TTS is played back.
The platform also automatically
gives you start and end event
for your TTS.
Here's has a super
simple example.
This is the SSML.
Here we have got two marks.
The one is called "here" and
the other one is called "there."
Here's our callback.
Now previously we
looked at the onUpdate.
Now we're looking at another
one called onTtsMark.
Works in a similar way,
but now the parameter
is the name of the mark.
So as the TTS is played back,
it hits each of those marks.
That name is parsed
into this callback
and then your code can
do the appropriate thing.
So here we are just
checking for here and there.
And we can synchronize
our game animation
based on those events.
So let's do a quick
recap on the life cycle.
The user talks to the device.
That user input gets
passed on to Dialogflow.
Dialogflow matches
an intent, which
then invokes fulfillment,
the code that
provides a dynamic response.
And now it provides a
new kind of response,
an immersive response.
Which gives a URL to the device.
The device loads the
associated web app.
When the web loads, it
initializes our Interactive
Canvas API and register
some callbacks.
Now the web app is ready to
accept events from fulfillment.
The web app is also
capable of invoking intent
on the platform.
So, if you've done a
conversational Action before,
it's very similar.
We're reusing almost all of
that existing life cycle.
Now we just have
a web app as a way
of providing a different
view on your action.
There are some technical
considerations.
As I mentioned, we add a header.
And on mobile devices,
it's 56 dp high.
On Google Nest Hub, it's 96 dp.
And on other smart
displays it's 120 dp high.
So don't put any content
or interactive elements
behind that area on the screen.
Also, on mobile devices, when
the user provides voice input,
there's like a
transient transcript
that the Assistant provides
of what the user is saying.
So don't put any
critical information
towards the bottom
of the screen.
From a technical point of view,
start with a responsive design.
So that will help you
to automatically handle
different screen sizes,
from small phones
to smart displays, which come
in different resolutions.
You can use your favorite
responsive framework or library
or you can just use
CSS media queries.
Also decide whether your game is
going to support both landscape
and portrait.
Users should be able to
use the mic or the keyboard
to complete any critical
conversational Actions.
You can provide access to
any non-critical interactions
via touch-only if you want.
Consider using the
HTML media element
to provide sound playing
locally within the web app.
This is very useful for like
sound effects or background
music.
It really elevates the
production value of your game.
Also very importantly, keep
your game logic in fulfillment.
If you are supporting
voice-only,
start with that first.
Then reuse the logic
to drive updates
to the interactive
version of the Action.
So think of Interactive Canvas
as another view on your Action.
There are some limitations.
So when you load the
web app, it actually
loads like a web page within
incognito mode within Chrome.
So that means no local
storage within the web app.
However, you can use
our existing API's
in fulfillment to
store session data.
No pop-ups are allowed.
No modal dialogues.
Also the origin is set to null.
That will have an impact
on things like AJAX calls
and requests for static media.
So you might have to
configure your web
server to support that.
Also, be aware that devices that
run the interactive experience
might have limited
hardware capabilities.
So this goes for
both smart displays
and all the mobile phones.
Don't expect the
kind of performance
you would get on
a desktop browser.
We've open-sourced
a very simple sample
that you can go
and try on GitHub.
It's a very simple animation.
It's got a little shape
and it keeps turning.
And then the user can use voice
commands to basically interact
with this animation.
The user could say change
it to red or change to blue
and then it will
actually do that.
Or the user can say stop
animating or start animating.
And then you can control that.
Very simple, but it
shows you the basic life
cycle of a typical
conversational Action.
So voice commands are
implemented in Dialogflow.
We do intent matching.
Let's take a look at the
code, the fulfillment,
and the WebLogic behind that.
So here in our
fulfillment logic,
we have gotten intent handler
for the welcome intent.
Note we're using
ImmersiveResponse.
We're providing the URL to the
https endpoint for our web app.
So that you should
be familiar with.
Here with another intent.
This is the intent
that gets matched when
the user changes the color.
And all we're doing now is
we're using immersive response.
We don't need to provide a URL.
We're going to keep
that web app running.
We provide state information,
which is just the color
that the user selected.
Here are [INAUDIBLE]
intents, and this is
for controlling the animation.
Here we provide a spin
value, which is just
the state of the animation.
Here's the web app part of it.
You have to include
our library, and we're
going to use the Pixi
JavaScript library, which
is a very popular framework
for doing JavaScript animation.
We also have some
coding main.js,
and we're going to look at that.
So to start with,
we just initialize
Pixi and we get a renderer that
actually draws the graphics.
There's also some
other variables
for the display
and the game state.
Here's our main callback.
And we are implementing that
onUpdate function callback
and we're just checking
for two things.
We look at the JSON
data that's parsed in.
We get the color value
and we get the spin value.
And then we synchronize
the local variables.
And this is a typical
pattern with data
from fulfillment and
synchronize with variables
within your game.
This one is interesting in that
you can also touch the screen.
So as you touch the screen,
it toggles the variable
that controls the animation.
So again we are just flipping
the value of the spin
variable in the game state.
Here's our main animation frame.
It's the function that
get calls for generating
each frame in the animation.
It does a little bit
of math and figures
out how to rotate the shape.
And then of course,
it uses the values
of the color and the spin
whether it should be animating
or not.
And that's pretty much all the
code that's in our samples.
So go and give it
a try on GitHub.
OK.
So as a developer, how do you
debug your Interactive Canvas
Action?
Well, our simulator
supports this.
So you can run it
just like you normally
do a conversational Action.
But in particular, you can
use the Chrome DevTools
to look at the iframe that
we use to host that web app.
So you can use all
the existing tools
for logging, for debugging, for
looking at the DOM structure.
It's all very powerful
too for debugging.
You can also test it on any
device with the same developer
account.
And, in our example, we provide
debug overlay, which just
provides the console output.
So it's useful for looking
at the output on a display.
We also use an open-source
library for the statistics.
And this is useful for tracking
how well our performance is
going on different devices.
What is the frame
rate, for example.
And that's all it takes to
create an Interactive Canvas
Action.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN HSU: Well, I hope you're
all excited to get started.
Before we get off to
the races, though,
I want to talk through some
design principles and some best
practices that
will help maximize
the impact of your content.
Let me get a quick
show of hands.
How many of you have
created a voice action--
voice game for Google Assistant?
OK.
A few of you in
the room and sure
there's several that are
following along online as well.
For you, there's a lot of
ways to enhance your voice
games by leveraging the visual
capabilities of the platform.
As Leon mentioned, the
backbone of a Canvas Action
is a conversational Action.
And so adding
visuals is actually
a very straightforward process.
In the act of building
your voice game,
you've probably thought
a lot about where the--
where the payoffs and
experiences that you really
want to reward the player are.
And using SSML, it's extremely
easy to align your animations
with your voices and sounds
that maximizes impact
for your users.
Another thing when you've been
building voice games that you
might run into is
some complexity
where something that might
be very difficult to describe
or done through
lengthy conversation.
For example, whose turn it is
or lengthy clues about visuals.
Keep in mind that these
moments might be easily solved
using visuals and leverage
that capability in order
to enhance your game.
Oftentimes, people are
nervous that maybe this will
create a situation
where their voice
action won't work as well.
But, because you
can determine what
the capabilities of the
surface you're on is,
you can actually create
different conversations
depending on what surface
your user is playing on.
Now, for those of you who
haven't created a voice game,
we're excited--
we're excited for you to
start developing games that
are bespoke for the
visual display device.
Games historically that have
been successful on the platform
have really leveraged the unique
capabilities of the platform.
What we believe is the
unique advantage of Canvas
and the Google Assistant is that
it enables a new interaction
model that just isn't
possible on other platforms.
For voice games,
we've already been
able to use Google
speech recognition
and natural language
understanding
to create complex--
to process complex voice inputs.
But the output is
strictly been audio.
For traditional games,
you've had access
to the visual surface.
But you haven't had access to
the more sophisticated language
understanding that Google
Assistant provides.
Interactive Canvas, along
with Google Assistant,
provides you this new way to
interact and create content.
One of the key important
things to keep in mind
is that the experiences that are
going to succeed in this space
are focused on voice
being the right input
for your experience.
If you simply map
verbal commands
to a controller input
and the user saying up,
go right, shoot.
You're probably not
taking advantage
of what the capabilities of
the platform fully allows.
If you've built
voice games and you
create you've
spent a lot of time
creating an immersive
world through text-only,
make sure that you're
taking a step back.
And realizing that
there are mechanics
that you can use with
a visual display that
will create a transformative
experience for the player
as well.
While on the technical
side, we can just
simply port HTML5 games.
We're encouraged and
interested in seeing
you create games that
really leverage the voice
component of the platform.
Let's take a look a
couple of examples
that really leverage this.
One thing that we've been
thinking about is word games.
I think there's a lot that
affords word games to be
on the platform.
Because of the fact that
visual puzzles are a way--
the visual capabilities
showcase a lot of ways
that you can engage
with word puzzles.
Crossword puzzles, anagrams--
like what we're showing
on the right hand there--
even image puzzles where
you're given images
and have to determine what
the clue are well designed
for the visual surface.
In addition, because they're
word games and the inputs
are actually words.
It actually affords the
user to speak those answers
with their voice.
A slightly more complex
example is an adventure game.
Text-based adventures were
super popular back in the day
and created an immersive world
when the only input a user
had was through text.
We have an opportunity
today to restructure
how adventure games work.
We don't have to
have text based input
where you're issuing
commands to your character.
Rather, let's create experiences
where characters in the game
are helping you
navigate the experience
through conversation, not
through direct actions.
So in this example on
the right that you see,
we've created a world--
and this is just
a simple example--
where characters are helping
you guide the conversation.
You're not in a situation
where you're like,
talk to character on the left.
The character is already
initiating the conversation
with you.
And astute users will notice
that the response to the
where we are?
Is based on the context
clue on the top right where
Big Ben is in the background.
And they'll recognize
that the answer is London.
Another unique
platform advantage
is specifically to
our smart displays,
is that they often
reside in common areas.
Because of this,
having games that
really focus on
social interaction
is something that's
unique to this platform.
And as well, being
in the home, you
have access to a very
unique social graph.
That of your family
and your home.
One way to engage with this
is through trivia games
as Lucky Trivia has done.
But there are other types of
examples where you're really
playing on the fact that
being in the same environment
allows social
interactions to flourish.
Additionally, rather
than having to setup
multiple types of
inputs or making
sure things are
connected, everyone
can use what they've already
have for input, Their voice.
Persistent games have
been popular in mobile
and really showcase
the progress of RPGs
as well as farming games.
These types of
environments-- where
users are making
continuous progress--
have been very popular there
but have relied primarily
on multi player
online interactions
to showcase the progress.
We have an opportunity here
where by focusing on the local,
we can create collaborative
experiences where
players within
the same household
are able to contribute to
the same persistent state.
In addition, we have access
to a local graph, not simply
through Google's APIs,
but as well as to the fact
that you're co-located
in the same area
and can collaborate together.
At the end of the day,
we're interested in seeing
what you have.
These are not meant
to be prescriptive.
They're simply ideas that help
the creative juices start.
We're really looking forward
to see what you create.
So, before we wrap up, I wanted
to spend a couple more minutes
talking about some
best practices
that we found in working
with Interactive Canvas.
First, as more
assistive devices--
assistant display devices
start to arise in the market,
it's tempting to create a
one-size-fits-all design that
actually targets
all the surfaces.
While creating
responsive design will
enable Canvas to deploy
your action to all
of these surfaces, it's
important to also keep in mind
that usage patterns
for these surfaces
are actually very unique.
Smart displays afford multiple
users are in common areas
so that multiple people
can engage with them.
And phones are better suited
for personal, quick interactions
that might take action
throughout the course
of the day.
Consider how your players are
going to engage with your game
even outside of your game.
Really focus on voice
forward interactions.
Conversations are
much more helpful
and create a deeper sense of
immersion for your player base.
And if you only use your
voice as a controller,
there is a sense of breakage in
terms of what the players are
actively engaging with.
Where possible,
set up situations
where you can interact
with characters,
rather than issue direct
commands to your character.
For traditional game
developers, it's
important challenge to realize
that these scope of what
voice commands entails
is actually quite large.
And so we need to
definitely leverage
our visual capabilities
to showcase what
the users can interact with.
If you're coming
from the world where
you've created
voice games, you've
already engaged in
this creative process
to come up with the right text.
But take advantage
of the visuals
to potentially simplify
those interactions.
Despite our best efforts, users
can still potentially get lost.
Or, in a social
setting, there might
be some crosstalk that
issues incorrect commands
to the platform.
In these types of
situations, make sure
that you're handling
the errors as well.
And potentially provide explicit
audio suggestions for the user,
so that they can get back
on track in your game.
Optimizing your
display is important.
With a visual display that
is right for visual pay off,
make sure that you use SSML and
other tools to really maximize
the payoff and
synchronize your audio
with your video animations.
Again, understand
that these devices
can be viewed at multiple
viewing angles and distances.
So make sure that your
text is sized correctly.
Once you've created your
game, figuring out how you get
discovered as vitally
important as well.
As Leon mentioned before,
setting up built-in intents
allow you to be cataloged
when the user says,
hey, G. Play a game.
In addition to this,
focus on making sure
that your games
are high quality,
have high retention
and engagement,
and leverage some of the new
technologies that we bring.
And finally, we're excited to
announce Interactive Canvas
for developer preview.
But your feedback is vital to us
for improving and continuously
improving the platform.
We'll help and continue to
develop new tools for you.
But your feedback in terms of
finding bugs and submitting
them in our public bug
tracker is important.
But also features that
you would like to see
and would like access to over
the course of your development.
We have a couple of more
recommended I/O sessions
that cover Interactive Canvas.
Voice and visuals
talks about how
you can create multi-modal
experiences that span
the smart speakers, as well as.
Display devices.
And how we built
our sandbox demos,
will showcase how we
created Jungle Dream
and how you can create a
similar experience as well.
Times are listed on here.
But if you happen to miss
them or aren't available,
they're are going to be
available as videos on YouTube.
And that's it.
Primarily, we want you to hit
g.co/interactivecanvas to get
started.
That will give you access to
APIs and to the documentation.
Leon talked us through
some code samples.
They're available on GitHub.
Make sure you talk to
us on social media,
Twitter and Reddit.
And we'd love your feedback
on our public bug tracker.
Thank you for coming today.
We can't wait to see
what you'll create.
[GOOGLE LOGO MUSIC]